actors often talk about the pressures of
auditions you know and everyone's been
there Daniel clear you have such a good
tip for actors you what I'm talking
about yeah yeah yeah if there's any
aspiring actors watching I think this is
brilliant advice when you do the
audition leave like it's just like don't
try and small talk don't try and be like
just do your thing and then leave just
like just run out the door I don't even
say bye yeah those if I did that and I
didn't realize I don't have a scene not
to put accents on your CV yeah yeah I've
lied a lot yes you got busted once in
you I've got what's it twice Oh
basically we've got spotlight you know
spotlight actors directory you have to
put your CV on there and obviously all
the accents and so I've seen a scene it
was actually going really well
the auditions going really well doing
this this is to anyone anywhere like so
Daniel says you can you can do Scottish
basically you can put like he put
Asterix it's like highly skilled so I
put a strict on all of them yeah
you could squash some light yeah okay so
I'm being it yeah in Scotland right now
and I'm like I'm like I'm like I started
in Midlands yeah
[Music]
you